there was this man wearing this hood
with a gun and popped in and then he
pointed it at my dad and fired him
riverdale is expected to return with a
bang and new photos are giving some
clues of what to expect when season two
premieres october 11. riverdale it's a
town without a zip code it is
it's got a lot more going on than you
would think here's the cast looking
somber on the new series poster posing
outside the town's famous diner pops the
official riverdale twitter account wrote
in the caption keep your friends close
your enemies closer and if you take a
closer look the broken diner sign reads
die that could mean archie's dad doesn't
survive season one's finale shooting
this man his goal was something else
darker
it's like the angel of death had come to
riverdale the cast has stayed pretty
tight-lipped about the fate of riverdale
series regulars in season two but here's
what e.t knows about cheryl blossom's
upcoming journey things are going to be
different now mommy
better
she does get colder and meaner believe
it or not no it's not possible she's not
right exactly that's what i thought too
um and she gets an unexpected love
interest is it someone that's already on
the show someone new i believe it's
someone new and it's somebody that you
wouldn't expect
meanwhile fans are going nuts over the
possibility of a cw show crossover
supergirl star melissa benoist dropped
by in full costume to visit betty and
veronica on set in between takes so
could melissa make a cameo riverdale
showrunner roberto gave fans a glimmer
of hope tweeting worlds colliding can a
crossover be far behind i need to know
who is next on your crossover bucket
list who do you want cara to share a
scene with who isn't next
am i right there's so many i want her to
be able to kick ass with
some of the girls